that's your superpower that's where our
samples yeah they can cut through glass
that's what they do right we need to get
into this building I know how turn me on
and twist me hey guys I'm Ryan right and
I am Brian shoes right she's one of the
stars of the gallows he is here today
and I'm gonna be going to Fresno
California to vlog the little haunted
mansion where's Carolyn say in
California so middle of nowhere maybe
you should come along too anyway from
screenrant's we're gonna check out ten
most unlikely action movie stars I'm
feeling a couple people on this list
it's never been possible to predict the
course of an actor's career but these
days blockbuster franchises can turn the
unlikeliest men and women into certified
action stars no one expected to see the
lovable Chris Pratt make the leap from
Parks and Rec to the buck star of
Marvel's guardians of the galaxy and
jurassic boy that's true he's just the
latest in a long line of actors who
transition from comedy or drama - big
time action can you never look back your
screen rants 10
unlike the a braver filmers Will Smith
The Fresh Prince gotta start rocking the
house in the late 80s before landing his
own TV show she is an actress starring
on skills Oh totally go guns blazing
against the backdrop of explosions in
May and I guess that's true in 1995 Big
Willie teamed up with Michael Bay and
Martin Lawrence for bad boys and he's
kept up his action chops ever since with
films like Independence Day wild wild
west I am Legend I Robot and suicides
well it looks the same and what's it
beckons minna black kate beckinsale
started her career in the UK in the ER
again are you the full she's managed to
leverage the exposure she got in Kenneth
Bryan as much ado about nothing and some
roles in films like The Last Days of
Disco and Pearl Harbor but Beckinsale
decided to ditch her celebrity persona
star is the gun wielding vampire so
reasoning under though francha just
watch this recently she hasn't made a
habit of appearing in many action films
since but seeing her show up in films
like Total Recall always reminds us that
she has just as much action experience
as her male co-stars so gorgeous that
day Sun Country that David started 1997
is Good Will Hunting and writing suit
maybe that David was immediately
cemented as an award little time on the
rise he started to get rules and other
acclaimed high-profile dramas like
Saving Private Ryan
and the talented I love that movie but a
few years later outside of his comfort
is gonna topple a CIA assassin I'm
ruining did then no one believed it was
still a list man what is it precious
party he's more than happy to
guns and films like ELISA and the
Martian still done in coming up this
actor seems to have practically cornered
the market on mainstream sci-fi these
days she's had major roles in James
Cameron's Avatar and JJ Abrams under
Dracula but still as well as to forget
Zoe Saldana skills in big-screen action
the losers and Columbiana didn't set the
movie world on fire and see colombiana
to show just how many ideas when the
results are bleed start flying as Gamora
and guardians of the galaxy Saldana
reaffirmed her ability to play lethal
and morally grey anti heroines
Bruce Willis Bruce Willis is practically
tracer up on a sitcom the established
itself is one of the biggest action
stars of all time with the Die Hard
series and a slew of other films ranging
from the Fifth Element to The Last Boy
Scout but we tend to forget that Willis
made his name in comedic films and TV
shows like blind date and moonlight even
after die hard to hit theaters Willis
would appear in comedies like death
becomes her and bonfire of the vanities
today it's almost impossible to
distinguish him from his action persona
but there was a time when the very idea
of putting Willis in such a film would
have been considered ridiculous
no way Nicolas Cage it's easy to imagine
a world where Nicholas Cage never
started the rock Conair or face off he
could have easily focused on more
comedies like Raising Arizona Fast Times
at Ridgemont High and vampire's kiss but
the rocks cute cages name in the realm
of big screen action above all other
types of films that is so cool that'll
be sure to show up yeah sure a driving
not to mention indie films like Joe
eclectic offerings like had apt ation
and thrillers like match statement
basically the man does everything bad
lieutenant - there isn't any profession
as a model and she started both Quentin
Tarantino's Kill Bill films where she
cut the image of Beatrix kiddo into
audiences Green was one of my favorites
right to imagine her on the catwalk when
she seems so at ease lopping off limbs
and plucking out eyeballs but believe it
or not there was once a time though
their goal wasn't a vengeance fueled
martial arts master she played Venus and
Terry Gilliam's The Adventures of Baron
Munchausen and helped Timothy Hutton get
his life back on track and beautiful
girls no wonder her transformation into
a hardened killer took viewers by
right Keanu Reeves Killman
Keanu became a fixture for all back
though here his new restore his
laid-back surfer dude persona in his
early history with teen films and dark
comedies Biebs didn't look after sound
like an action hero but when he packed
on some pounds and [ __ ] his hair for
speed in 1903 but the part surprisingly
well to this day Reeves continues taking
on non action oriented projects films
like the lake house side-by-side and A
Scanner Darkly
but he still puts out hard-hitting
action movies like yeah a man of Tai Chi
keeping his action trading talent or
this Johansson Shawn of what a dangerous
Black Widow first became noticed her
talents you're so hot yeah absolutely
yeah Ghost World
Scarlett Johansson earned even more
paris' years later for her performance
in Lost in Translation and the girl with
the Pearl Earring
she started dabbling in action in
Michael Bay's 2005 film the island but
in 2010 she became part of the Marvel
family with Iron Man 2 that's the part
where she went from small supporting
roles blockbuster notoriety now she's
making a name for herself as a
full-blown
action heroine not only in the Avengers
and Captain America to see a soldier but
even a starring role in Luc Besson as
Lucy Liam Neeson yeah there is this
towering daughter she wears I got to the
scholar to in his day before ever
bringing his particular set of skills to
the taking student Neeson had limited
supporting roles in Excalibur and chrome
but he defined himself as a dramatic
actor through his work in projects like
the mission Michael Collins and
Schindler's List now you can't see him
in anything but taken pummeling of
European Fugs and parachuting a tank out
of an airplane looks like Rob Roy has
gone from fighting English aristocrats
to wrestling wolves whatever field is
shipped of genres it's working and
action fans can't get enough nice so
what do you think of our lives did we
improve as your actresses we define to a
pro that become believable action stars
let us know in our comment section and
don't forget to zoo they might have a
channel for more videos like this huh
they hit they breathe I just hit the
mark on it didn't they Shia LaBeouf Shia
LaBeouf
Shia LaBeouf dude he
even Stevens to transformers yeah
eagle-eye yeah but I get to get more but
I guess like to this day though you know
how many more current people Will Smith
is one of those careers that I greatly
admire because he was on Fresh Prince
you watch Fresh Prince of bel-air even
today and then you watch it one of his
movies it's not distracting at all that
like if I watched that Bruce Willis show
I'd be distracted watching Bruce Willis
but watching yeah but watching Will
Smith he took that comp it's he has such
an interesting transition because he
took that comedy went into action while
bringing the comedy and then he's
transitioned into like really hardcore
dramatic roles and not so much comedy as
much and which is more action and it's a
really impressive career shift that he's
managed to do over the years and just go
from Fresh Prince where it's such a
goofy character and not a smart dude
either and then to go to like being such
a hardcore leading actor like people
like Anne I am Legend and stuff totally
respect and he's gonna be in Suicide
Squad now so that's pretty cool Kate
Beckinsale I was introduced to her
through underworld actually I know she
was a federal Harbor but my introduction
was underworld so I was kind of
surprised she was on this list because I
wouldn't call like an unlikely action
movie star but maybe it's because I
didn't follow her a career before but
she does fit the mold of an action movie
well that's what I was going to say with
Bruce wills as well as like I was
introduced to Bruce Willis like diehard
yeah yeah exactly and so I didn't know
him before him but these actors know how
to take roles they've done before in
their work the action genre and a lot of
ways has shifted especially when you see
like Matt Damon and the Bourne Identity
I mean he's doing born five actually
here I remember when the Bourne Identity
came out there was so much doubt about
it cuz a Matt Damon's career was already
dipping to get an action movie they're
like Matt Damon in an action movie but I
feel it's roles like the Bourne Identity
that have really redefined the action
genre today where you're able to get
good character and great actors there
was a time where there was action stars
you know Stallone Schwarzenegger Bruce
Willis even like that didn't go as deep
into the yeah they were just action
stars
and then you have these great actors
transitioning into these action movies
and they're bringing like great
character to of the green depth you get
a full-on character where the actions
kind of secondary to the character so
now and Matt Damon like blew people away
with the Bourne Identity
I remember Minority Report came out
around the same time so everyone was on
board for Minority Report but I remember
a lot of people walking away going I
actually enjoyed the Bourne Identity
more the movies fantastic also entertain
oh yeah they're intense they're all
awesome Matt Damon's great I love all
three of them too
he said one of the transitions that I
was listening to an area at one point
the transition that he made he didn't
feel like he had the action thing in him
the director was like you know just go
take some boxing lessons and he got this
stance and he got this like body
transformation and it kind of like eased
him into the role and it gave him this
confidence that he didn't know that he
had and then he was able to transition
into high so that's kind of cool it's
like you know you just you just shared a
really good insight and points that was
thanks man I really like Matt Damon yeah
Zoe Saldana she's someone who's really
like she's not superstar but she's on
her way to getting there especially with
these action movies gets tough because
she is an actress and actresses tend to
get pigeonholed she is an actress yes
it's a fact of life
actresses intend to get pigeonholed and
the fact that she's getting like diverse
roles and an action genre it's like
she's gonna be a superstar one day I
really feel it coming habet are those so
crazy that it's like it's her but it's
not her yeah I mean I love that and
Nicolas Cage I remember that when he was
doing a lot of action movies like
face-off is one of my favorite action
movie
yeah like that's one of my favorite
action films of all time his face off he
does a lot of like crappy action movies
today it's really sad to see what's
happens because every once in a while he
just comes out with a randomly really
good film yeah
like that lieutenant you were pointing
out love that you just out of nowhere
there's like a string of shitty movies
and then he does his graver is the other
one which sells he's selling guns to
people overseas oh no overseas uh
that's what chair let oh yes yes he
makes he makes Idaho out of the shape
cook yeah yeah that was his favorite
scene you really related to the Thurmond
to me isn't an action star cuz they're
only action movie I can really think of
it's like she paycheck with Ben Affleck
and she did Kill Bill most of her movies
are not action films so I wouldn't call
her an action star but her performance
in Kill Bill is phenomenal from volume
Assyrian this is all I saw from your
side
she'll nipples dude even that's for you
film is like yeah I feel it I feel it
that's where all my I got this
enthusiasm goes strains yeah there's a
lot that goes into selling a role in an
action role and uma Thurman is a great
example of what I mean by taking a great
actress and putting her in an action
movie that character required a lot of
depth and a lot of performance
especially by volume 2 but when she's
doing the fighting totally believable
she's got the demeanor down the body
language everything about her is perfect
in that role that's your number one
that's my number one I would I would
I've been do the nasty what's that
tossing salad I like salads
you know I'm referring to BUTT STUFF
right
sex yeah what Scarlett Johansson's
someone to who's really transitioning
into these action roles and yeah man but
then the number one choice that I found
was Liam Neeson what I'm excited for is
that Martin Scorsese's next film is
starring him in Andrew Garfield that I
know in exciting well I don't know about
forgot what it's called something about
priests that's so exciting to me because
I know Liam Neeson from being a great
dramatic actor who suddenly did taken
taken took off now he's just making Lea
does action films I can't wait for him
to transition into like another girl or
you're on my mind right now just hearing
that fact yeah yeah those three names
Liam Neeson is another one where he does
like a lot of these same [ __ ] movies
now I always noticed the reviews
especially I brought it to me those
capsules will go movie sucks believe me
Stan still does a great job anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out ryan
in the gallows being released october
13th on DVD and blu-ray and if you
missed it this summer because you should
have seen in theaters you should have I
hope you did they did yeah dude that
movie I did those bloom house movies are
so cheap to make if it sold one ticket
you wouldn't made profit already we shot
it for $12 you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter I also have a vine a
pair of scrub two more than him and
follow us there because if I get an
eyeball on you have mine yeah then
follow him on vine I don't I got some
funny ones you'll like him they're so
dumb I feel like that guy at the party
who's like yeah I'm also in the film
business I got some sketches and stuff I
work check it out sometime yeah and I'm
like I don't know if I should trust this
guy but whatever you shouldn't trust me
why won't I toss your salad callback